hello everyone this game was played in
2003 and this is well six years after
Kasparov famous match against IBM's deep
blue this is a Garry Kasparov vs. frites
x3d and well it was a pretty unique
match as Kasparov never had any border
pieces in front of him he had special
goggles and he saw a 3d floating board
in front of him and well he didn't move
any pieces he just said the moves and
the voice recognition program recognized
the move he wanted to play and the move
was made automatically and Kasparov got
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
participate in this match if he drew the
match you will get additional $2,500 the
$25,000 and if you want to match you
would get additional $50,000 so this is
a game three in Game one they drew the
game game to Kasparov lost it was one of
his greatest blunders of his career and
this is game 3 so the outcome of the
match is on the line and Kasparov really
needs to win this one to get back into
the match the match consisted of four
games so let's see this game Kasparov is
white and the fritz x3d is has the black
pieces with Knight to f3 Knight f6 c4 e6
Knight to c3 c5 d4 and c6 the same slot
defense and Kasparov goes III and in
round 1
well 3 SEC 3d played the Knight B to d7
but here he played a 6 probably to avoid
any additional preparation by Kasparov
and here because part of actually played
c5 as he thought that well I I've seen a
couple of interviews with Magnus Carlsen
where he says that it's it's quite
strange that cusps are lost his match
against the deep blue because at in 1997
computers were weren't really strong
enough to defeat us to defeat Garry
Kasparov and well one of the reasons
Kasparov lost that match was that he
played the tactical lines against
against IBM's deep blue and here he goes
for c5 so
he's going for our close strategical
position as the general believe his
computers really suck at positions like
this so Knight B to d7 and B for
expanding on the queenside
a5 is played and now b5 we have b5 and
the Queen to a4 as part of threatens to
capture this pawn on c6 Queen to c7
defending and now Bishop to a3 we have E
for night to d2 and Bishop to d7 and
Kasparov pushes b6 and well already this
is quite a quite a positional
achievement by Kasparov as he has this
beautiful pawn chain from f2 to b6 and
after black moves it with the Queen for
example Queen to d8 now it's only a
matter of time before Kasparov captures
this a a 5-1 you can't really defend
this pawn Kaspar goes h3 not along any
9g 394 ideas castles and knights the b3
going for that
a5 pawn bishop 36 and now rock to be one
he's not in a hurry to capture that pawn
isn't going anywhere
Bishop back to e7 we have nice - a five
nights the b8 Bishop to b4 Queen to d7
rook to be to Queen three six and as you
can see in this position Fritz doesn't
really have a clear plan he's just
maneuvering his pieces left and right
Queen to d1 a knight F - b7 a3 Queen to
h6 and Knights back to B 3 and now ok
because power 1 this a 5-point and his
next part of the plan is to push this a
pawn all the way to a six and then well
after the exchange happens be captured
on a six then he will have a pest be
pawn so Bishop to h4 Queen to d2 adding
additional protection to F 2 we have
Knight to f6 and now King to d1 Kasparov
wants to shift his king all the way to
the Queen side Bishop to e6 has power
play scheme to see one
rook to d8 rook to c2 Knight B to d7 and
Kings to be two and the kingís walk
completely safe here as there is no
fridge doesn't have any chances of
breaking this pawn chain Knights to f8 a
forest blade Knight to g6 a five by
Kaspar of night back to be seven and now
Spyro pushes ha6 the bishop here is
defending this pawn so drug cannot
capture it so be capture Sunday 6 and
knife to a5 not blocking this a pawn and
now Kasparov has created this past be
pawn we have a rook d2 b 8 g 3 Bishop to
g5 Bishop to g2 now getting the other
rook into the game Queen to g6 King to a
one King to h8 Knights - 8 - Bishop to
d7 Bishop to see 398 Knights the b4 and
well Kasparov is almost ready to grab
this a6 pawn and black doesn't really
have anything to play for no plan seems
seems like a good plan for Fritz King
back to g8 not rook to be one Bishop the
c8 trying to protect that a6 pawn rook
to a to Bishop 286 Bishop to f1 now also
attacking the a6 pawn Queen to b6 Queen
to d1 tonight C 2 F 6 and now Queen to
a4 and now this c6 pawn is attacked
three times so Bishop to b7 defending it
and now Knight captures on b7 rook
captures an b7 and Knight captures on a6
and ok casparo once again is up a pawn
and now well he has a very clear plan
here he will double up rooks on da file
and then well simply exchange pieces and
put this beep on to victory Queen to d7
Quintus back to see to King to h8 black
doesn't really have anything to play for
here and here Kasparov played rook to b3
and in this position both both the Fritz
x3d and the team operating
the program decided that they will
resign this game as well like Mike
doesn't have anything to play for here
and the whites play White's plan is
completely straightforward simply double
up rooks on da file exchange everything
all the rooks and then push to be be
point to victory so they didn't see any
reason to continue this game and well
this is game 3 cuz part of really
strangled strangled his opponent the
free text 3d and I remember the first
time I saw this game I remember this
huge bone train and well I actually
never forget this game it's a it's a
very nice game especially you know for
positional chess so yeah the the fourth
game was also drawn so at the first and
fourth game of the match were drawn
Fritz won the second game and Kasparov
won the third game this one and a spar
one the additional $25,000 for drawing
the match against Fritz x3d so yeah this
is the game I do hope you enjoyed it if
you would like I will also show you the
game discuss power of lost against Fritz
x3d that's considered to be one of the
greatest blunders of his career as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
and I would like to thank Kaplan Keith
such inside puppy ready and the Rendell
route for a contribution to my channel
thank a lot to really appreciate it
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon